you
Macerich master is a new game from MMO
publisher and see soft it features
elements of both a classic MOBA game and
a dungeon crawler I recently got
hands-on with the MXM alpha and got to
experience both these avenues of
gameplay when I look back on my hands on
time with game the first thing that
comes to mind is the large amount of
content on offer from the very start the
player versus player aspect of the game
will be familiar to anyone who's played
any MOBA game but with one major change
you get to pick two characters instead
of just one and exam sets itself apart
from other games in the genre by
offering players the option to instantly
tag out to another master players choose
two masters at the beginning of each PvP
match and knowing when to tag out adds
another layer of strategy tagging can be
used to dodge certain moves or even
avoid death when a master is tagged out
they'll slowly regenerate health fault
benched
combat moves pretty fast and I found a
lot of it to rely on skill shots and
twitch reflexes movement plays a big
part I chose the control scheme which
moved my character around using WASD and
hitting spacebar to jump some maps have
verticality with obstacles to jump over
and platforms to leap onto and timing
dashes using right click was super
important for dodging attacks it's easy
to jump into the arena for a match that
goes for about 5 minutes you once the
timer ends the team with the most kills
wins the game also offers matches
against AI so that players can ease
themselves into the game play at their
own pace at the beginning of each match
a master selection screen is presented
which allows players to choose the
characters that they want to play and
equip skins skills or stat boosting
nodes I was quite surprised how similar
the screen looks compared to the League
of Legends champion selection screen
right down to the skin selection submenu
outside of pvp arena matches MXN offers
dungeon crawler style content as well
dungeons are short enough that they
don't quite feel like a grind and boss
fights have enough action to bring each
area to a satisfying clues the story
missions introduced each feature of
gameplay gradually and although I
thought there was a lot to do the
tutorial missions were great in helping
me gradually understand the game's many
systems some of these segments were
peppered with some cheesy cutscenes to
break up the tedium but fortunately
everything was skippable completing
these missions and me rewards which I
could use to unlock new masters in their
skins and there were a lot of different
options on offer among these were
characters from some of ncsoft other
popular MMO games including Guild Wars 2
wildstar ion and linear to there are a
fair amount of options available for
changing up a masters appearance
skillset and stats stats are changeable
by equipping nodes and players can mix
and match nodes to go for more offensive
defensive or supportive builds according
to their preference overall I can see
potential for a lot of strategic depth
when approaching in maxim's PvP arena
and when that becomes a little too full
on there's always the dungeon crawling
aspect to fall back on to as well my
time with the Alpha was a fun mix of
fast-paced competitive play and
satisfying monster killing and it's
piqued my interest enough for me to be
curious about what the full game has to
offer when it's finally out
you